small businesses across the country are
very worried about the democrats push
for a 15
federal minimum wage the congressional
budget office estimates the move could
put
1.4 million people out of work and many
mom-and-pop shops simply can't afford to
double their payroll
but democratic congressman rokhana says
he only likes businesses who can afford
the wage hike they shouldn't be doing it
by paying people low wages we don't want
low wage businesses i think most
successful small businesses can pay
a fair wage i love small businesses i'm
also worried but i don't want small
businesses that are underpaying
employees it's fair for people to be
making
what they're producing and i think 15 is
very reasonable in this country
joining me now new york post columnist
carol markowitz
hope i said your last name correctly
carol thank you so much for being here
tonight
so you are a small business owner in new
york you understand what it means to
to run a payroll to make money that goes
at the door
what is it about these politicians who
are completely out of touch with the way
that small business runs in this country
well i think none of them have been
small business owners and i think it
really shows
uh you know when i when i had a small
business it was a lot of well if you
can't afford
to have a 401k for your employees i
literally heard that that maybe you
shouldn't exist or
if you can't afford this is
pre-obamacare if you can't afford to
cover healthcare
for your employees that's you know
another reason not to exist
so i've heard all this before and so has
have all the other small business owners
and i think what we've really learned
over the last year
is that most of our politicians have no
idea what small business owners do
or what they have to do to survive and
this is just the latest example of the
elites really not understanding
what a small business owner goes through
to survive i think it's really
interesting because democrats always
claim to be the party of
the little guy the party with the worker
and yet in this case we've seen over the
past year corporations like amazon
and big box stores are the ones who are
allowed to stay open
during the pandemic well mom and pop
stores in a lot of cases were forced to
close down
and now we're having the democrats
pushing through this 15
minimum wage which will continue to
crush small businesses
right that's absolutely right one of the
most telling quotes from the pandemic
was when andrew cuomo was somebody
had asked him about businesses going
back to work and he said oh those people
can go get jobs at like amazon or
at any of the um businesses that were
allowed to open
at that time and it was just so gross
and so
telling that the guy who kept collecting
a paycheck just didn't understand what
it was to build a small business to
watch it prosper
and then to watch it disappear this has
been the most
really exposing year where we saw
that they just don't get it and this is
another example of that and it's really
unfortunate i think that
we don't want to live in amazon land we
don't want the big box stores to be all
that we have and yet you don't
understand that the policies that you're
pushing will lead exactly to that
well you mentioned elitism right i mean
ro khanna
represents silicon valley which of
course is a place where the 15
minimum wage is a big check easy to pay
but
it also is a reflection of the democrats
one size fits all
big government socialism policies that
lead to the center of the country or
places that have more affordable living
that can't pay that 15 minimum wage to
be forced to do so anyway
right that's absolutely right it's just
having no idea what goes on in the rest
of the country they don't understand
that the real minimum wage is zero
when the business cannot afford to pay
15 an hour and that's what's mandated by
the law
they're going to close it's not like
they're going to somehow find a bucket
of money that they hadn't previously
found they're just going to close their
business
and put all these people out of work
that's exactly it silicon valley does
not understand what the rest of the
country is
going through and neither does a lot of
other major city governments that want
to impose
their view on what the rest of the
country should do yeah you know i grew
up in a family that had a small business
and
you know looking back at what we did and
the opportunities that i had to learn
in that place i mean i think that small
businesses are great places for people
to start because you're able to climb
more quickly whereas if you start at the
bottom of a corporation
it's much more difficult to make it to
the top to make more money
and you would know that as a business
owner yeah absolutely and you know we
all want successful small businesses to
become successful
big businesses right it's not like we
don't want them to grow and
and be able to to pay their employees
more but listen you have to start
somewhere and not every business can
afford to do what the congressman
suggests
obviously he's never owned a small
business and that's why he thinks
that this is okay well carol you have
owned a small business
in new york new york city for example so
we're happy to have you on as the expert
on this topic thank you so much for
coming on appreciate it thank you